- Don't have sex in bars.
Just drink, have fun, and go home.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- The best way to get a
drink or shot for free
is be someone who comes
in often and tips us well.
If you treat us well, we treat you well,
it's really that simple.
- Be a big tipper.
I always remember people that tip big
and I always get 'em a
shot or buy 'em a drink.
Learn the bartender's names.
Like, get to know them
when it's not super busy.
- Make a connection.
We're more likely to
share a drink with them.
The worst way to get a free
drink is to ask for one.
- By the way, I can give you other stuff
for free other than free drinks.
A lot of times I will get
you free food or snacks,
something like french fries.
- That's a total lie.
Asking for no ice or
less ice does not change
the other ingredients of the drink.
Nothing else changes.
You're literally just getting less ice,
which is exactly what you asked for.
- I don't know, less ice just means
disappointment most of the time.
- It means you get less in the
cup or you get a smaller cup.
Unless you tip and then
that changes everything.
When customers ask for,
like, a stronger drink,
I just put, like, two or
three drops in the straw,
just to make them think it's stronger.
It kinda burns the back
their throat real quick.
- The amount we put of alcohol will be
the same no matter what you ask.
You can always pay for a
double shot or you can have
the cup full of ice and
then it's less mixer,
which will make the flavor
of the alcohol stronger.
- Sounds like they want something strong,
but they don't wanna pay for it.
If you want a strong
drink just order a double.
- This, this is my number one pet peeve.
"Yes, I see you, you're
there, there's people
"that are also here
waiting for my attention."
This is not helping your case.
- When people say, "Oh, just fix me
"your favorite drink to have."
No, what I like is not necessarily
what you're gonna like,
not necessarily what your
best friend's gonna like
or what your mom's gonna like.
Most of the time I'm just
gonna end up giving you
a vodka soda with a splash of cranberry.
- If you wave your cash or snap at me
or do anything obnoxious, anything that,
like, you as a human
being would find annoying,
you're gonna get less attention.
- If you snap at me,
you're not getting served.
Like, point blank and a period.
- It's always the people
that, like, schmooze you,
those are the worst tippers.
Your compliments and,
like, your love for me
doesn't pay my bills.
- The best way to get
a bartender's attention
is to look at them and smile.
It's like, I mean, when you meet somebody
for the first time.
- The best way is just to
look like you're ready.
Most of the time, bartenders are
standing in their section of the bar
to see who's ready and who's not.
- So we're always looking
for you, don't worry.
If you stand there, waiting, catch my eye.
Make sure I saw you and then you're good.
- Patience is rewarded behind the bar.
- Wait your turn.
Don't worry, I will get to you.
You will get your drink, you'll be fine.
Nobody's gonna say no to, like,
a handshake with something in it.
- Cash is always king.
Like, always slip cash.
- If they did a really
bad job and you didn't
have a lot of fun give ten percent.
If they were fine and
you were kind of okay
give fifteen percent.
And if they did a good job
and you had a good time,
you should give a twenty percent tip.
- It's a decision that you make.
Twenty percent's a good place to start.
- Do I drink on the job?
No.
- Yes, always, every single time.
- I like to call it quality control.
- Oh my God, you're gonna get me fired.
I used to a lot.
I can finish a whole bottle of Jamison
before I even sell one.
You make more money not, though.
- I just wanna make you happy.
Drink what you wanna drink
and if I can make it,
I'll make it good.
(upbeat instrumental music)